I mean you just told me things in the
past few hours that you should have told
me like many many years ago I don't know
I think it's mood you're crying
no why are you crying
[Music]
one of the most pivotal things that a
father teaches his son is how to shave a
real rite of passage the video you're
most excited about yeah I remember you
teaching me how to shave it was a big
moment I remember my father teaching me
oh [ __ ] and it in some cases just like
one of the last really big things that
your dad teaches you so as a Father's
Day gift I'm going to shave you like you
did for me back when I was kid thank you
are you afraid yeah you feel comfortable
no I will say if I mess up at all it's
because you taught me huh you're in good
hands whenever you're at the gut place
do you feel trapped I feel trapped
whenever I'm in the chair either at a
barber shop or the dentist okay I uh oh
boy I don't know how to do this to you
but I will try and give you the full
barbershop experience right like a pond
and my lab side setup no is it weird
that I'm so close to your face
when someone's doing something to you
it's always a little bit unnerving right
especially someone who's not qualified
to do it that's exactly right yeah this
is not how you shave I open up not
really little weird that's not
chloroform right yeah yeah might be
better for the buns if you knew how wet
my shirt is right now what do you use
Gillette alright
yeah homebred sure I feel like I'm
buying him like a kid I don't you think
it's weird for you think about me yeah
you just gonna fall asleep I'm using my
sniper you know so the first thing the
thing that you taught me when I was
learning how to shave is don't be afraid
to draw blood I'd never sell
jamón gonna hurt me unless you go
sideways you want to stretch your skin
in any way or did you have to do that I
don't know okay I'm tryna you don't have
to go all up to my eyes and so I have no
beard around my eyes though you have one
big nose hair coming right out of your
nose no really
hmm one two three oof see that how's my
dad's nose mm-hmm
can't get more intimate than that dad
while I have you captive in a barber
chair why don't I ask you some questions
like there's a lot I know about your
life and then there are things I don't
know about your life and we talked about
this like there's some things fathers
and sons don't talk about you remember
when you lived far away from us yeah how
long is that per few years ago Oh
for you do you ever feel like we didn't
get to know you very well as kids
Oh sometime so I didn't spend much time
with your eyes yeah I know I feel like
my memory of this is like more extreme
but when I was like teenager and like
preteen I feel like I was really angry
alone I remember like yelling at you and
Mom and especially you and like being a
kid is like frustrating and scary and
angry but I never thought about how that
must feel the father but the horse and
walk of father you try to spend more
time with your children so that there
was I missed a lot I didn't spend a lot
of time with your eyes but you had a
good mom yeah
miss Betty Kendall Clary mom so you guys
should appreciate where we did but then
she left and then we were with you
right right so what was your early
relationship with mom like well I met
her senior year in college and I knew
pretty much right away that I wanted to
marry her but I wasn't ready
really yeah so we dated and then we
broke up and we dated and we broke up
what only that at church someone came to
me said hey dawn we think you should
help teach some Sunday School okay this
is a mom one and mom was already kind of
like in charge of the youth group you
know she was really good with the youth
and no really pretty and and really
smart and we seemed to be compatible and
you know she had lost strengths or I
didn't and had some strength to achieve
might not have had and together it
seemed like it was gonna work out well
one of the first movies we went to was
when Star Wars first came out what very
first time we were both blown away equal
we both liked it yeah that's a good sign
yeah oh yeah I had no idea that you
broke up with my mom before while I was
an idiot because they're mature and it
was an idiot obviously I thought I
needed to date other people for a while
and I didn't just wasn't wasn't the same
she just had a really great sense of
humor that I appreciated and
[Music]
you know the things that I appreciated
her with her enemy getting are the same
now but there's so many other things I
appreciate about her that actually
became more more intense with kids and
having children actually has made our
relationship stronger but maybe I think
that I got to know you better after you
divorced right right
[Music]
[Music]
so when your dad died when you were held
I was the last three months old how did
he die he died River stroke get a stroke
hmm and then when your mom died well she
left us oh yeah we're doing have any
communication but she left you right
why'd she leave you
I
I'll really
whose high school how'd you take care of
yourself in high school well I have a
good family of gorillas too you know
they help your crying no why are you
crying well I'm just confused why I mean
I only had one grandma it's just mom's
mom but what she was alive when we were
kids
yeah you never tried to reach out to her
well yeah I didn't try it's cuz she left
you
mmm-hmm what what do you mean she
doesn't look she's left the family right
I had to take care of yourself my high
school teacher corny one day this
Saturday
uun Chrome I said why because you're
going to funk my grade to go down be
Franck you will be beggar you better
study go College so you know I really
appreciate to the teacher is like my
father he guided me what I am now so you
know for me even I didn't have a father
and I everybody need a father figure
somebody who can discuss cuz like I know
that there were I didn't mean it but
there were times that I screamed that I
needed you there are times that I told
you to [ __ ] off and leave my room yes I
know you did that but you didn't really
mean it you were just angry but house
like
I don't know how's that feel is it dead
well I'm smarter and more mature them
and so when you said that I knew to take
it with a grain of salt I guess I've
never apologized for it and I felt bad
about it so I wanted to say I'm sorry I
just understand why you don't say any of
this when we were growing up I guess
what's my mistake
mmm now we can talk yeah we're just not
comfortable hmm James because Korean
culture because I didn't know my father
and my mother left so I'm not very proud
to talk oh yeah but I just feel like you
didn't have to go through that by
yourself all the time well I wish you
all that maca stone poison all the sides
make a very wick I don't know if I've
really told you this yet but Arielle and
I are actually going to try and start
having kids this year Wow what do you
think about that um I feel like it's
something that we've been talking about
for a while yes I've noticed the
pregnancy books in there
in the bathroom but I just I worry that
having a kid will be so challenging that
it'll stress our relationship in a way
that
we're ready for I mean you're not gonna
be ready yeah you don't you're gonna
have to just like work it out
every parents going to be different
you're gonna you're gonna do fine what
do you think of Becky Oh love her
they're so happy that she she's sweet
and intelligent and you know she
[Music]
kind of understands maybe whatever
peculiar a burger ways we may have and I
am excited to have a kid and I think the
entire way I'll just be thinking of the
example that you and mom set for me good
and I wanted to thank you when I was
growing up and when I was dealing with
depression you and Mom always supported
me supported me creatively end it meant
the world to me then and it still does
you could set very good examples for the
kind of people we should be so we we owe
a lot of that to you it'll be a terrific
father a great dad because you're one
who somehow can relate to visit every
age for one thing I mean plus you care
and you both you and Becky you who was
just marvelous
I have confidence I imagine fatherhood
is challenging
yes this is not an easy thing but it's
worth it I learn every day your preciate
to your life it's morning when the way
car used to lie that's a life you enjoy
to go through about your parents I'm
glad it even if it's for a video that we
finally got to talk about a lot of this
I think I learned a lot about you today
and I'm really I'm really glad to know
that you always wanted to have kids
mm-hmm all right do you want to do it
not awkward hug now like a regular hug
yeah say weird okay I love you dad Susan
I love you more love you most
huh longer more than doing thank you
that was pretty good yeah I'm sorry
about happy
well done fear sorry that's alive well
even though you didn't have a dad I have
a good dad thank you yeah every father's
dead Thank You Ned
you're a great kid I love Avery much me
too
thanks for coming all this way to LA for
a day to do all this fun stuff do they
love you dad
look for Zack oh you are wet hahaha I'm
so sorry
[Music]